bears
beats battlestar galactica
this is the worst
no question about it i am ready to get
hurt again
ed truck was the manager before me
horrible
he hated fun it was like oh ed truck is
walking toward us
why are you the way that you are
honestly every time i try to do
something fun
or exciting you make it not
that way i hate
so much about the things that you choose
to be
i love inside jokes love to be a part of
one someday
and you can knock it out [ __ ] identity
theft is not
a joke jim millions of families suffer
every year
parkour
corporate needs you to find the
differences between this picture and
this picture
indel has told us there are at least
seven okay i already see one given
okay they're the same picture
your department's just you right yes jim
but i am not easy to manage
jan is about to have a baby with a sperm
donor and
michael is preparing for the birth of a
watermelon with dwight
now this baby will be related to michael
through
delusion as i was saying right now we
are going to talk louder
okay our prices have never been low you
have to talk louder never been lower
louder son buttocker our prices have
never
been lowered
no god no
god please no no no
no oh my god okay it's happening
everybody stay calm what's the procedure
everyone what's the procedure
it's britney [ __ ]
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot
i'm serious about this stuff i'm up the
night before
pressing garlic and dicing whole
tomatoes
i toast my own ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from malone's
for generations
it's probably the thing i do best
my perfect valentine's day i'm at home
three cell phones in front of me
fielding desperate calls from people who
want to buy one of the 50 restaurant
reservations i made over six
months ago i declare
bankruptcy
if i could menstruate i wouldn't have to
deal with idiotic calendars anymore
i'd just be able to count down from my
previous cycle
plus i'd be more in tune with the moon
and the tides
hey nobody cares nobody cares
if i had to i could clean out my desk in
five seconds
and nobody would ever know i had ever
been here
and i'd forget to
wish i could but i can't well can but
won't
should maybe but short
jim james jimothy
whenever i'm about to do something i
think would an idiot do that
and if they would i do not do that thing
my mind is going a mile an hour and i
feel god in this
chili's tonight all took a life here
today
you did the life of the party
worst thing about prison was that was
the dementors
welcome to the hotel hell check-in time
is now checkout time is never
sorry i annoyed you with my friendship
what is that
it is your birthday period statement of
fact i am beyonce always
i am dead inside
ah i'm gonna kill myself
wow i'm going to kill myself and it's
your fault
well well well how the turntables
holly you and i are soup snakes
i am aware of the effect i have on women
depression
isn't that just a fancy word for feeling
bummed out
dwight you ignorant [ __ ] do you think
that smoking drugs is cool
do you think that doing alcohol is cool
occasionally i'll hit somebody with my
car
so sue
oh me you can't get diseases from a bird
where are the turtles
where are they should i burn this place
down when i had a chance
i'm not superstitious but i'm i am a
little stitious
stanley barack is president you are
black certainly
i saved a life my own
am i a hero
i really can't say but yes so
you've come to the master for guidance
it's cece she's never gonna do anything
wrong
do you have a question kelly yeah i have
a lot of questions number one how dare
you
yeah okay
well this is gonna hurt like a mother
it's not a pyramid scheme it is a it's
not even a scheme per se
it's
i have to go make a call i knew exactly
what to do but
in a much more real sense i had no idea
what to do
shut up about the sun shut up about the
sun
no one uh asked you anything ever
i'm very fast
[Music]
i feel very blessed
[Music]
did i stutter sometimes i'll start a
sentence
and i don't even know where it's going i
just hope i find it along the way
where where
where dwight seems like you already know
where
this is [ __ ] stop stop stop stiff
stop
boom roasted you have a lot to learn
about this town sweetie
would i rather be feared or loved
um easy both i want people to be afraid
of how much they love me
you know what i'm gonna start dating her
even harder boy have you lost your mind
cause i'll help you find it
well happy birthday jesus sorry your
party's so lame
this was a successful unveiling there's
too many people on this earth
we need a new plague
dancing it is a primal art form
used in ancient times to express
yourself with the body
you